there's a country that always always
always always appears in the headlines
of international newspapers and it's for
two main reasons well one of them soccer
and the other is economic crisis the
problem my friends is that lately these
headlines are having more to do with
crises than football
I am of course talking about Argentina
[Music]
look it's hard to say but Argentina is a
country that is as allergic to reforms
as it is addicted to crises when
everything seemed to be going well 2018
suddenly became very very complicated so
much so that Mauricio macri's government
has been forced to ask for a bailout
from the International Monetary Fund so
now you might be thinking really a
bailout Argentina again well yes you
heard it right
Argentina the country of tango is back
on the ropes so listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
April and May of 2018 haven't exactly
been great months for Argentina
[Music]
la condición a Mandela Seton cada dia
mas complex's y por varios factories tan
subiendo data center is the subiendo
petróleo Sandoval ole ammonia devices
American this in just a few weeks the
peso was depreciated by 20% going from
an exchange rate of one u.s. dollar for
20 pesos to an exchange rate of 1 dollar
getting you 25 pesos but you know what
it's not exactly surprising since the
beginning of 2018 Argentina's currency
has depreciated by 25% and if we
extended that timeframe to 5 years could
you guess how much the peso has
depreciated since then well the reality
is that it's been an absolutely brutal
80 percent depreciation
[Music]
make no mistake though the plummeting
exchange rate isn't the problem it's the
consequence you see if you were
Argentina's real problem lies in its
addiction to public spending and I'm not
saying the public spending is slightly
higher than they can afford here they
have such high public spending that
Argentina simply has no ability to
afford it in the last 57 years we spent
53 years with the state spending more
than it collects that is with a fiscal
deficit and during those 53 years we had
four huge crises now we're fighting to
avoid a fifth one
jose-luis suspect an Argentine economist
but I know what you might be thinking
right now you're probably thinking Simon
what the hell does public spending have
to do with the pesos depreciation
well actually much more than you'd think
so let's go through it step by step
[Music]
Argentina is facing a triple time bomb
it has a huge external deficit a huge
public deficit and 250 billion dollars
of external debt of course as you can
imagine both the deficit and the debt
have to be paid and here's where that
first big problem appears years and
years of protectionism devaluations
hyper regulation and very high taxes
indeed Argentina is one of the countries
with the highest business taxes on the
entire planet
now all of this has stopped the industry
and the Argentine economy in general
from being competitive it's also caused
capitalists to flee the country long ago
in search of refuge somewhere else I
mean it's all sounds pretty logical
right and so what's the result of this
well since there's no money at home
Argentina has become very dependent on
foreign financing according to the
Institute of International Finance most
almost 64% of Argentina's state and
corporate debt is denominated in dollars
and other foreign currencies
that's why both the volume of central
bank reserves and the exchange rate are
very very important of course on the one
hand they need to pay for imports and
deal with debt payments but since
Argentina has a negative external
balance that is it consumes more dollars
than it gets it needs someone to lend
them those dollars
it needs investors to bring money into
the country and my friends if investors
don't lend that money because they don't
trust the country then Argentina has a
problem a really big problem on the
other hand if the peso depreciates then
obviously it loses value and folks let's
be honest here nobody wants to have
their savings and a currency that
devalue so quickly
[Music]
[Applause]
so well what do you do in that situation
well essentially what you do is you rush
to exchange all of your pesos for a
stronger and more stable currency and
well that's exactly what the population
are doing and that is causing the
currency to collapse even further and of
course that leaves two reserves being
consumed even faster but all right
having said that let's take a look at
their government see both nestor
kirchner and especially Cristina
Fernandez de Kirchner the two previous
presidents of Argentina they'd like to
spend quite freely when they came to
power in 2002 public spending was
equivalent to 23 percent of GDP when
they left when it was more like 40
percent but now you might be wondering
well what did they do with all the money
well basically they hired public
employees to win votes and multiplied
subsidies thus in only 13 years public
employment soared by 60% to give you an
idea of how extreme this was today 35
percent of employees in Argentina work
for the government
[Music]
Jodie conocer paisa con más de sera so
economic social and agarra en las clubs
de su crecimiento suisa Roseau uno puede
encontrar en la difensa restricted l su
propio cine Theresa's como esta dozy
Sociedad A's
la clavier AC Evangelic la vie de
sorrows open
and get this in seven provinces in the
country there are more public workers
than there are private it really is a
crazy situation
[Music]
[Applause]
and of course given that the government
didn't have enough money to pay for all
of this year after year they continued
to register a huge public deficit now as
you might know the Kirchner's couldn't
go to the international markets first
because their investors didn't trust and
then second because the country was
already in default the seminar on
internet in bar agarra la bajada
Argentina en estados unidos invent Aaron
Berger LSAT le toursad Berger satury
Janel Akana
and of course if you don't pay your
investors obviously the investors don't
lend you any more money
all right so what do you think they did
then yeah they used every populist
politicians favorite machine the money
printing machine
they simply printed nude pesos to pay
their public expenditure Matins
establishing a currency cap which meant
limiting the amount of money that
Argentinians could take out of the
country so they wouldn't beat up their
dwindling reserves and the question is
what happens when these policies
continue well inflation soars due to all
the new pesos in circulation and foreign
investors of course do not want to come
near you and so it was in these
circumstances that Mauricio Macri came
to power
[Music]
the Mochrie plan
when Mauricio Macri came to the Casa
Rosada air plan to implement reforms
little by little that were commonly
known as gradualism Pareto implement
emotional political economic a gradually
cave okay clear Aroldis a Trekkie no
dejaron en nuestra cuenta públicas
cuidando loss victory vulnerable a's
yell mimic info creciendo kelly and
rossi must simply Odessa Roger and truth
is have actually been quite successful
the business climate has improved some
subsidies have been reduced and in a way
they regains the international investors
trust but out of all the hard things
they needed to do they've only done the
easiest ones what they haven't achieved
in more than two years of governing has
been decreasing the public deficit or
inflation and in spite of having access
to the financial markets the Argentine
government has continued to prints bills
to maintain the huge public expenditure
that of course means more inflation this
chart shows how the money is growing
that is how the central bank of the
Republic of Argentina continues to issue
more and more pesos
[Music]
but our a now you might be wondering
what wasn't mauricio macri that dude he
was supposed to change things well gary
was but slowly see this all has an
explanation
batteries team's idea was to carry out
reforms little by little to attract
investments and make the Argentine
economy grow if the economy grew the
government would raise more money and
would not have to make cuts meanwhile
little by little as they regains the
international markets trust they would
be able to issue a debt and thus reduce
the need to print bills in this way
within a few years Argentina would get
rid of their deficit limit inflation and
would start to grow again and Macri of
course would maintain his political
capital to continue winning elections it
all sounds like a pretty great plan
right
[Music]
well so far things have actually kind of
gone as plans but just hold on a moment
because things have now changed and it's
mainly for two reasons first after two
and a half years in power it's hard to
understand how the public deficit
inflation and taxes continue to
skyrocket gradualism has become
something like racing and arthritic
turtle
and seconds because the Federal Reserve
of the United States has begun to raise
interest rates C for public debt in the
United States the ten-year bond is
already yielding 3%
[Music]
and of course many investors now ask
themselves if the US debt which is
supposedly the less risky asset gives me
a reasonable return why on earth would I
keep lending money to Argentina where I
see no changes well that's exactly what
has caused many people who were
interested in investing in Argentina to
turn away from it and for this reason
macri's government has decided to resort
to the International Monetary Fund to
obtain a credit line with which to face
the debt maturities of the upcoming
months and the future
can you imagine what would happen if a
new default occurred before the 2019
elections you see everything has to do
with the government's behavior and if
you think about it for a moment it's
actually very sensible the patience once
held for Argentina it's gone what
investors and Argentine savers find
themselves saying is fine if you want to
spend more than you can go right ahead
but just don't do it with my money
and this is not only in regard to public
spending but many other reforms that
make it easier to do business and this
it brings up a key question is it time
to abandon gradualism aggressive
therapies for gradualism now folks
making reforms is never an easy task but
I think it's time for the casa rosada
that's the argentinian version of the
White House to ask itself a question
shouldn't they be haps try employing
more aggressive measures well you know
what first let's take a look at the
historical evidence which do you think
has worked better gradualism a calm step
by step change or aggressive therapy
while we can see a good example of huge
transformations in the former countries
of the Soviet orbit when the communist
model collapsed in 1989 many countries
employed drastic changes almost
overnight while others offices for more
gradual measures as you know as the best
results that was long as it made the
most reforms
countries such as Estonia Latvia
Lithuania Poland in the Czech Republic
opted for a more drastic change that is
making reforms as quickly as possible
[Music]
and yeah it was pretty hard at the
beginning but soon they began to grow
and they achieved all kinds of
investments to such an extent that today
these countries which were mostly poor
in 1989 have a higher standard of living
than Portugal or any Latin American
country on the other hands those who
applied gradual reforms countries such
as Ukraine Romania Tajikistan and
Armenia well let's just say things
haven't gone so well either in economic
or social terms anyway folks this is a
decision the macri's government has to
make it has to decide whether to take
advantage of the IMF's money to carry
out strong reforms once and for all or
continue with gradualism and let's be
clear if argentina doesn't fix its
public debt and stop printing bills the
future does not look good
borrowing money is in good governance
good governance is creating basic
reforms in Argentina there's an
elephantine gigantic hypertrophied state
that needs to be slimmed down they need
to cut public spending James Bailey in
addition the model simply doesn't work
the Argentine government has never spent
so much and despite that it's been
decades since there was so much poverty
and so much violence
but will naturally listen well only the
future will tell but now it's your turn
what do you think should they continue
with the gradual reforms or is it time
for a faster change well leave your
answer in the comments below as well as
in this survey and I know this was a bit
of a dense subject but I hope with this
video we were able to shed some light on
this and I really hope you did enjoy the
video so please do hit that like button
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast to provided
the vocals in this episode that we're
not mine and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]